- - Bonsoir!
- - Elle a été députée du bloc,
mamairesse de Longueuil, juteuse
avavec Paul de l'autre côté.
SeSera-t-elle la prochaine dépue
dede Sherbrooke pour la CAQ?
ShSherbrooke appartient à Québec
sosolidaire actuellement.
C'C'est intéressant, tour de tae
tatable!
DoDonc retour de Caroline St-
HiHilaire.
- - Oui depuis qu'elle a quittéa
jojoute, à la fin de l'année
dedernière tout le monde
s's'imaginait qu'elle revenait n
popolitique et on pensait que ça
seserait la seule combustion de
MaMarie Victorin mais finalement
onon sort des sentiers battus ac
ShSherbrooke.
C'C'est une candidate de prestie
dede longue carrière politique,
mamais en même temps Sherbrooke
n'n'est pas si connu des élèves
élélecteurs.
- - Ce n'est pas elle qu'on voit
susur les images!
- - Tout éclat maintenant.
DoDonc elle a une longue
exexpérience politique, peut-ête
momoins connu à Sherbrooke, mais
çaça montre qu'la CAQ veut
vrvraiment offrir une oppositioà
QuQuébec solidaire qui a le comé
etet la circonscription avec
ChChristine Labrie.
C'C'est une circonscription quia
chchangé à maintes et maintes
rereprises de partis politiques.
CÇa été M. Charette qui a été et
babattu dans cette circonscriptn
cicirconscription.
DoDonc ça va être intéressant de
reregarder ce que ça donnera cee
fofois-ci.
- - Michel?
- - La réaction que j'ai eue qud
j'j'ai vu que c'était officiel e
meme suis dit : Monsieur Legault
vava gagner plus que 100 comtés
C'C'est une excellente candidate
ilil y a là une habitude des
dédébats et vous avez parlé de
nonotre ami Paul mais il y a pln
d'd'enregistrement de Madame St-
HiHilaire contre le troisième ln
etet le gouvernement du Québec t
cocontre l'étalement urbain.
DoDonc si on fouille dans les
vivieux rubans, ça pourrait
ututiliser contre elle.
- - Oui Jonathan a tweeté un
exextrait de la joute où elle
ététait fortement contre le
trtroisième lien.
MaMais ça fait parti de
l'l'évolution des candidats, ele
pepeut dire qu'elle voit les
chchoses d'un autre angle.
- - Oui comme Shirley Dorismond
ququi avait critiqué le
gogouvernement parce qu'il ne
rereconnaissait pas le racisme
sysystémique est assez présenté
popour François Legault et a gaé
dadans Marie Victorin.
CÇa arrive souvent politique et
prprobablement que elle aurait
poporté plus les couleurs du Pai
ququébécois.
EtEt les afficher souverainiste
ououvertement et elle va vers la
CACAQ donc ça montre la difficué
que ressent le bloc.
PoPour Sherbrooke ça va être
inintéressant parce que...
etet Christine Labrie n'est pas
babattue.
QuQuébec solidaire a tendance à
s's'incruster dans les
cicirconscriptions ou les députs
sosont réélus.
MaMais c ce n'est pas parce ques
coconnu qu'elle va l'emporter.
JeJe pense que les gens de
ShSherbrooke vont faire leur chx
susur différents critères que la
nonotoriété.
- - Il y a le campus ou si de
l'l'université.
IlIl vote davantage Québec
sosolidaire.
MaMais sa notoriété faite quelqe
papart en créant une vraie
babataille dans Sherbrooke qu'on
vava suivre effectivement.
AlAlors voilà, Madame St-Hilaire
auaux prochaines élections.
JeJe pense qu'elle va présider.
QuQu'on a ce cas-là le présidere
coconcret de la CAQ, c'est une
bobonne éducation.
- - Oui il n'y a pas de vocation
pepermanente, donc c'est pas la
prpremière à changer des parties
etet ce ne sera pas la dernière.
MaMais elle va devoir s'expliqur
dedevant la force de la faiblese
dede ses explications, les
élélecteurs vont la prendre au
sésérieux ou pas.
DoDonc il va falloir qu'elle pae
àà cet exercice en disant
popourquoi elle a changé d'idée.
- - Mesures sanitaires des
vovoyageurs.
EtEt donc délègue sa cause dans
leles grands aéroports du pays.
LaLa chef de l'opposition
ofofficielle a attaqué le
gogouvernement là-dessus.
JeJe ne vous présente pas
d'd'extrême est assez simple: ee
dedemande de faire le ménage das
leles mesures parce qu'il y a un
gogoulot d'étranglement d'attene
1h1h30 deux heures dans un
apappareil parce qu'on est pas
prprêt à les recevoir sous peu
pupuisque le gouvernement fédérl
dodoit faire le ménage au plus
vivite des mesures sanitaires qi
totouchent les voyageurs?
- - Il y a plusieurs facteurs qi
exexpliquent les délais à actues
dadans les aéroports canadiens t
leles mesures sanitaires en sont
unune et aussi le fait qu'on
ininterroge les passagers sur
leleurs symptômes.
QuQu'on fasse aussi des tests
alaléatoires dans des terminaux
ququi ne sont pas adaptés donc n
dodoit réduire l'espace.
DoDonc oui ça ajoute des délais,
mamais aussi la pénurie de main-
d'd'oeuvre, il manque de gardies
etet de responsables de ce que,l
mamanque aussi de douaniers.
OnOn a probablement pas embauché
susuffisamment dans la dernière
anannée parce qu'on avait passéu
momonde à l'aéroport donc on ne
vovoulait pas payer déjà à ne rn
fafaire de certain ça passe à la
reretraite donc il y a ça aussi.
CeCe qui est inquiétant c'est
ququ'on n'est pas dans la saison
totouristique forte, si on a de
trtrois heures d'attente à
ToToronto, et qu'on ne peut même
papas entrer dans l'aéroport pae
ququ'il est plein, imaginez ce e
çaça va être au mois de juillet
ququ'on va recevoir les Canadies
ququi reviennent, mais aussi les
totouristes étrangers.
IlIl faut trouver une solution,e
nene suis pas spécialiste de la
lologistique, mais on doit
s's'asseoir avec les grands
aéaéroports pour régler les
prproblèmes parce que ça sera ue
cacatastrophe dans quelques
sesemaines.
- - Michel?
- - Je voudrais dire que je ne
susuis pas technique, je me
dédébrouille bien avec mon
orordinateur et j'ai utilisé dex
fofois arrive Cannes depuis
ququelques mois et les deux fois
çaça n'a pas fonctionné et j'aiû
reretourner derrière la Lune.
EnEn plus il ne vérifie pas, vos
dedevez donner une adresse sur
vovous allez passez votre
ququarantaine, vous pourriez
memettre le château de Windsor e
n'n'est pas utile et d'autre pat
ququand vous avez des tas de ges
ququi attendent en ligne que ce
sosoit Dorval ou à personne, c't
unune belle place pour que le
cocoronavirus se déplace et
ininfecte des gens.
IlIl y a des gens en tapon c'est
pipire que d'abandonner quelques
memesures sanitaires qui resten.
JeJe n'ai jamais compris pourqui
onon insistait tant et on est le
dedernier.
- - Mais si on avait été, à caue
dudu tout début, traumatisé et
ququ'on ne peut pas aller trop
vivite, on a comme oublié de
fefermer la lumière ou de
l'l'allumer!
- - Six sur qu'on a toujours été
unune barre en retard dans le
dodomaine des transports dans la
COCOVID.
LaLa question que doit se poser
c'c'est: est-ce que ces règles
sasanitaires sont encore utiles?
JeJe pense que le masque dans ls
trtransports c'est faisable est
popossible de le conserver.
C'C'est souhaitable.
D'D'ailleurs renvoie aux États-
UnUnis que les autorités
sasanitaires disent qu'il faudrt
quque le tiers des Américains ds
leles régions où c'est plus
didifficile, recommence à porter
lele masque à l'intérieur parce
ququ'il y a une augmentation des
hohospitalisations.
- - À New York .
- - Oui et savoir s'il faut garr
lele passeport vaccinal, c'est e
auautre histoire.
AÀ quoi ça sert exactement?
IlIl faudra que le gouvernement
féfédéral nous l'explique parce
quque s'il est décidé de se serr
dede cet outil pour convaincre s
gegens de se faire vacciner, je
pepense que ce qui ne veulent ps
sese faire vacciner ça ne va pas
leles convaincre stocker aussi
l'l'idée de dire qu'on ne veut s
quque la COVID se réponde,
d'd'accord, mais on exige plus e
papasseport vaccinal comme le
CeCentre Bell ou il y a plein de
momonde donc est-ce que c'est
lologique?
J'J'en use suis pas convaincu.
IlIl faut avoir plus
d'd'explications pour savoir à
ququoi tout cela est utile.
- - sécurité des élus fédéraux,n
vava regarder ensemble une scène
ouou de Jagmeet Singh se fait
poususser et ce faire traitait e
vevendus.
Et la question que ça pose :
cocontrairement Québec, les élus
etet les chefs libéraux ne sont
papas suivis.
LeLe premier ministre suivi, mas
papas les autres.
EsEst-ce qu'on doit changer se
llâche selon vous?
OnOn est en train de dire qu'ily
a a une pluie de menaces, mais l
y y a quand même plus de menaces
ququ'on en avait il y a 25 ans.
- - Oui la réponse courte si ou,
onon a un peu d'angélisme canadn
enen pensant que nos élus ne
seseront jamais apostrophés sura
rurue.
OnOn a même eu des menaces très
didirectes à l'Assemblée natione
etet à la Chambre des communes.
DeDes gens qui sont rentrés
ararriver dans ces enceintes.
CeCe qui les empêcherait de
atattaqué un ministre dans la r?
LaLa ministre se promène Mélanie
JoJoly sans voir personne qui la
susurveille.
CÇa fait des années que les élus
dédénoncent cette situation main
pepeur d'aller de l'avant comme
c'c'est un aspect de tabou comme
s's'on ne voulait pas commettre
auaux EÉtats-Unis où les
rereprésentants sont mieux
prprotégés.
JeJe pense qu'on est dans une
sosociété qui s'est radicaliséeà
drdroite ou à gauche et est plus
popolarisée que jamais.
SiSi on veut que nos élus face u
trtravail, ils doivent être miex
enencadrés top c'était le cas ac
lele convoi des camionneurs, coe
FrFrançois Blanchet.
MMême chose pour Jagmeet Singh.
TaTant mieux que si des choses
exexceptionnelles se produisent
ilils sont mieux protégés, maisn
dedevrait réviser cela et prende
coconscience que si élus sont ps
sosouvent apostrophées.
- - On voit les roches lancées à
MoMonsieur Trudeau.
EnEn campagne ils le sont tous,
ilils ont la même protection que
lele premier ministre.
- - On a peut-être pas besoin
d'd'aborder garde du corps armé
avavec chaque ministre, mais les
auautres corps de police pour
rérégulièrement des évaluationsu
dadanger et des évaluations de a
sisituation.
IlIl y a a des situations que
mamaintenant, mon collègue Patrk
LaLagacé avavait écrit que le me
alallait pas bien, bien en
lalaissant dans lala rue et même
dadans le métro.
IlIl y a des comportements
agagressifs.
SiSi la GRC c'est cela, elle pet
didire que dans certains une
pépériodes, je pense que celle-i
seserait une bonne période, de
didire que de façon permanente l
popourrait leur fournir de la
prprotection surtout pour des
chchefs de parti.
- - Pourquoi pas permanente?
- - Il ne faut pas non plus cour
leles jambes, j'ai vécu aux Éta-
UnUnis et je peux dire que Nancy
PePelosi...
n'n'importe lequel.
OnOn ne voudrait pas qu'il soit
cocomplètement coupé.
- - Mais au Québec les chauffeus
sosont armés.
- - Je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils st
ararmés.
JeJe pense que celui du ministre
dede la Justice et les premiers
miministres sont armés.
- - Moi je pense que ça serait
bbête que quelqu'un soit
asassassiné comme l'avion au
RoRoyaume-Uni l'année dernière.
JeJe pense qu'on devrait fournir
plplus de protection de manière
sysystématique aux ministres
féfédéraux.
C'C'est le cas au Québec et c'et
unun peu étrange comme l'année
dedernière de voir le ministre
FrFrançois-Philippe Champagne qi
ararrive au Québec et qu'il y a
dedeux ministres du provincial
sosont la et si l'égard de du
cocorps du provincial sont oblis
dede dire à M. Champagne, voicie
memeilleur accès pour rentrer
paparce qu'il y a des manifestas
etet c'est compliqué.
C'C'est t pas normal que ces geà
DaDavid Deschamps grand stress,l
y y a plus d'agressivité, non ce
n'n'est pas que sur les médias
sosociaux.
N'N'attendons pas que quelqu'un
sosoit vraiment victime de quele
chchose de regrettable.
- - On a peur d'aller là, on a
pepeur des symboles.
OnOn va prendre nos retraites et
çaça sera pas réglé.
VoVote de confiance de Jason
KeKenney?
OnOn aura les résultats.
VoVous vous attendez à quoi
StStéphanie?
JeJe ne vous demande pas de
prprécision, mais il est un peu
dadans un coin et pour se sortir
dudu coin il a besoin d'un bon
scscore-?
- - C'est certain, c'est le Pari
coconservateur réuni mais c'est
plplutôt le Parti conservateur
dédésunit depuis un certain tem.
OnOn le voit, la contestation et
flflagrante il y a des nouveaux
papartis qui émergent.
LeLe Wildrose et le Buffalo.
OnOn voit que le très contesté t
çaça va prendre un vote solide n
sasa faveur même s'il est élu, l
vava peut-être vouloir aller
l'l'élection pour avoir un signl
enencore plus puissant..
CeCe n'est pas nécessairement
gagagné parce que la chef du NPD
enen profite de cette grogne.
C'C'est vraiment un vote qui va
êêtre déterminant et peut-être
ququ'on aura des élections en
AlAlberta plutôt que plus tard.
- - l'exercice va amalgamer
MoMonsieur Kenney.
QuQu'il gagne ou qu'il perde,
c'c'est quelqu'un qui va arriver
auau moment des élections très
ababîmées.
- - Alec?
- - Il a mit la barre très basse
ilil a dit que s'il avait plus e
5050 % des voix il allait reste.
SeSerra que c'est comme cela que
çaça se passe, généralement si n
nene finit pas avec trois quarts
dedes voix, le chef est fragili.
EtEt les gens veulent sa tête
susurtout les gens plus connus
cocomme Daniel Smith peut se
prprésenter aux élections.
IlIl y a des gens qui ne vont ps
sese contenter de 52 % et le
lalaisser en place, ça va lui
prprendre un très bon résultat t
lala question c'est: qu'est-ce
ququ'il va faire s'il a 61 %?
EsEst-ce qu'il veut se maintenir
ouou les couteaux vont sortir.
- - On aura le résultat plus tad
enen soirée.
MeMerci beaucoup et bonne soiré.